What do we eat? Does it matter?
Absolutely. OK, so, and...
We have to eat healthier, we have to think
about food
but we have to get away from calorie counting.
And the reason why we have to get away from
calorie counting
is because I think it's an imperfect, no nay,
its' a lousy science.
Because we never consider caloric availability
when we are dealing with calories.
What do I mean by that?
If you eat a 100 calories of sugar, and you
actually eat it or drink it,
you will be probably get a 100 calories of
sugar out.
Into your body, because your base level of
fuel is sugar.
If you had 100 calories of sweetcorn, corn
on a cob,
and you peeked into the loo the next day,
you'll know that you have absorbed nowhere
near a 100 calories of sweetcorn.
Yet, if you take 100 calories of sweetcorn,
dry it,
pound it into a flour, turn it into a flour
tortilla and eat it.
Then you'll get a lot more calories out of
the exact same amount of corn.
So here we have a situation where you go to
Tesco's, whatever,
other supermarkets are available, where you
actually go:
100 calories of sugar, 100 calories of corn
and 100 calories of a flour tortilla.
It's exactly 100 calories but they all have
different caloric availability.
You could take the difference between a steak
and a mince that's been put into a lasagne
and cooked for four hours.
So you have a steak that's been cooked rare
400 calories versus that.
That is always going to be calorically, the
steak, less available.
So what you eat does matter. OK.
So in other words just calorie counting doesn't
help us in any way,
the quality of the calorie does matter.
When the calorie is absorbed, it is a unit
of energy, it's an SI unit...
well that's not an SI unit, a mega Joule is
an SI unit,
but it's a unit of energy that is, yes, every
calorie is equal.
But because we can't get at all the calories,
some calories are more equal than others.
So yes, what you eat matters.